[Music]
remember all of Britney Spears at
beautiful pics and videos from her
recent Hawaii getaway
Aloha well it turns out it wasn't all
great the pop icon revealed a near-death
experience during an interview with BBC
Radio 1 on Wednesday I went to Hawaii
like a couple of weeks ago and it was
beautiful the waves were like 6 feet
tall I completely embarrassed myself I
went out and I I thought it was like a
wave pool you know and I'm like oh this
is so nice and refreshing and it's
beautiful but the thing I didn't think
about is when you come back you know the
waves really come in hard and I got
sucked under for like five minutes
literally almost drowned and I'm like
where's my security there just let me
die here you know and then and then I
came in again in another way to be on
Earth Day I kind of made up with myself
but it was fun to say the leaf you know
I got to experience what it was like you
can't be done by a how did security come
to that thankfully Brit Brit
ok back to performing in Vegas and
gearing up to promote her new album a
glory out Friday
she'll also hit the VMA stage this
weekend for the first time in nearly a
decade